vous comprenez l'inquiétude des parents
c'est une décision très difficile de
faire grève durant cette période
d'examens aussi bien durant des
surveillances que maintenant pour rendre
les notes les mettre en vente sur
internet séduisons décisions difficiles
et une fois de plus 5 qui vient du fait
qu'il ya une absence de dialogue depuis
un long moment
est ce qu'on peut leur répondre à ses
parents c'est que cette inquiétude et le
concerne le très court terme on a
partage mais plus fondamentalement
encore elle concerne le moyen terme de
long terme
qu'est ce qui vous motive dans ce
mouvement nous on se mobilise contre une
réforme qui va avoir un des conséquences
très importantes sur le lycée notamment
et qui va accentuer selon notre analyse
qui va accentuer les inégalités entre
établissements une école qui va
accentuer le pardon une réforme qui va
accentuer le rôle de tri social de
l'école et ça ça nous préoccupe beaucoup
on est inquiet on lutte contre ça en
fait on lutte pour les élèves
prioritaire
irez-vous jusqu'au bout de la rétention
des notes
jusqu'où ça ira l'idéal ça serait que
monsieur blanc caire nous entendre avec
eux plutôt que de parler de sabotages
disent oui qu'il est prêt à en envisager
ouais voilà de sanctions plutôt que des
sanctions il pourrait y avoir un
véritable dialogue
soyons fous même une abrogation des
différentes lois qu'ils essaient de
mettre en place